there have been protests in DC this week
as the Supreme Court considers whether
to strike down Biden's unconstitutional
quote-unquote student loan forgiveness
plan the very people who waive their
degrees around as evidence of their
superiority
now want us to pay for those degrees you
cannot treat us like a children and
expect us to be your sugar daddy at the
same time she'll be my sugar mama
I gotta get me one of those if anything
it should go the other way
if you want your loan forgiven you
should have to give up first of all all
of your precious titles and degrees
in fact you should have to give your
titles to us the people paying the bill
then at least it'd be a swap instead of
a straightforward theft
if I'm paying for your PhD I should get
it it belongs to me
I bought it not you
look at me I'm the PHD now look at me
sure I'm the captain now